[Music]  the following sentences have never ever  been uttered before in human history I  [Music]  don't quite understand all the symbolism  in that Vin Diesel movie I can't get  this improvisational jazz song out of my  head what ho tis a fair maiden walking  past our construction site I rescued a  shelter dog but I don't like to make a  big deal out of it  Vice President Biden the president needs  to talk to you  oh I'm hoping my daughter grows up and  marries a magician Wow cool selfie stick  they finally got it right with  Expendables 3  [Music]  as an Armenian jeweler in Glendale I  have a natural aversion to Cologne I  [Music]  can't stop writing celebrity apprentice  fan fiction happy 10th anniversary  couple that met at a Kid Rock concert Oh  boner alert the new Valpak is here  they're their coupons you get in the  mail levian again would you worm  [Music]  bartender I'll have another Cosby  Politan  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  you